nous passons des semaines et des semaines à filmer les
moindres détails avec des coffres de banque avec des
distributeurs automatiques de billets le carrelage des
salles de bains avec le plus petit des tuyaux les
zones entre le premier étage et un
deuxième étage entre les bâtiments nous avions
ces caméras qui étaient vous savez plein
plein 4k  appareils photo numériques mais avaient des objectifs
aussi gros qui pouvaient parcourir et
capturer ces choses pour chaque ensemble que nous aurions,
nous construisons ce genre d'
ensembles miniatures ces ensembles macro vous êtes petit
d'ant-man et il court sur le
sol ou traverse  un tapis, je
voulais vraiment ressentir ces textures et le
rendre vraiment tactile pour pouvoir
avoir un point de départ à partir d'un
objet réel qui nous fait gagner des centaines d'
heures en essayant de faire correspondre et d'utiliser la
technologie comme nous le faisons nous avons  les
ressources pour rendre toutes ces surfaces
réelles mais nous pouvons toujours déplacer notre
caméra autant que possible, cela ressemble à
un espace réel très interactif car
c'est un homme de chêne un gros Fupa 20 bluet wat un
blu-ray DV  D vidéo la mode est un numérique